all right well let me welcome you to
this the second session in this
quarterly series hosted here at the
Shorewood Public Library originally was
entitled women you should have read but
now I think that's a little too preachy
and sword is calling a women you should
read and the idea is focusing on exactly
that women who women thinkers who often
don't get enough attention you know and
so I'm a philosopher so I'm focusing
primarily on women in philosophy but we
made if we go on we may look at other
figures as well I think it's very
important in philosophy because even the
ones that we have a lot of material from
walk and don't get read they don't get
into them and like Mary Wollstonecraft
for example so this one is done eloise
who is known primarily for her
connection with Peter Abelard in the
twelfth century we will be following
this up in the fall with one unmarried
Wollstonecraft and then finishing in
December with Barbara Cavendish the
first one was on Elisabeth of Bohemia
and her relationship with Rene Descartes
and Queen Christina of Sweden and other
people and so what I do in this is
generally I have Innocents notes
prepared and make a few general remarks
and then we've got some biography to go
through others the lives of these two
people Eloise and Abelard are very
interesting in their own right and
they're entangled in this beautiful the
tragic love affair that goes on the rest
of their life so we'll talk about that
I'm also going to talk a bit about the
context of intellectual life and
religion and culture in the 12th century
and on that general time frame maybe
a little bit further and then what I
want to focus on is what the few things
that we have written by her which are
these letters between her and Peter
Abelard and I'm less interested in
talking about Abelard himself in parts
they want to put the focus really on her
but you can't talk about her without
trying to enamel eye and she actually I
think herself wouldn't want to talk
about herself what about a hemline and
then I also talked about the afterlife
of these two lovelies in European
culture down down to the present now I
am NOT a I am a medievalist
but these are these are not people who I
particularly focus on in my research I
get interested in them in part through
teaching a class on love friendship and
desire and I use their letters to
exemplify something of that so I you
know I had to do a lot of sort of
backgrounds left there's still some
things that are a little bit hazy mean
so one of the other things by way of
general Marxism before I do that - so I
should mention that there is time for
Q&A at the end but but if you ever want
to raise a question or make a comment I
can always answer it and then come back
to when we're talking about a pretty
experienced and getting back end on
whatever track we're on now other things
by way of general remarks so what we
have from Eloise unfortunately is a very
small amount of what she probably did
right at her her lifetime let alone what
she thought and said in there last time
we know that she was a brilliant scholar
almost unique in her timeframe not only
in terms of women but in terms of
scholarship in general we also know that
she
positions of responsibility in a
monastic community and in doing that she
would have been involved not only in
giving direction to the nuns themselves
but in a lot of dealings of the outside
world as well and members of other
religious houses and we have very little
of that as well unfortunately what we do
have is primarily her correspondence
with Peter Abelard the man who she ends
up marrying also brilliant solid oh yeah
brilliant scholars all right no no it's
okay they they have a couple different
separations but they do get married in
the course of it and one of the ironies
of it though we're going to talk about
that later is that so they're there you
know as both of them were fornicating
before they get married and she gets
pregnant all right so we've got a very
common kind of story right but it's not
a shotgun wedding because Peter wants to
marry her she actually doesn't want to
marry him I'll talk about why in a bit
he wants to marry her in part to make
you know make her uncle's not no longer
so so hostile to them and and basically
they essentially do the right thing
linen they do the right thing but then
they wind up you know not benefitting by
doing the right thing and so this is one
of the irony that she'll talk about in
her
letters so let's talk about their their
lives and I created a timeline for you
that some of the things happening in
Europe and some of the things happening
in other ways we know less particulars
about her own life and more about
Abelard Peter Abelard actually he chose
the name Abelard by the way and knowing
scholars are quite sure why because it's
an unusual name but what we see
happening is they are both coming from
let's call it northern France she is
she's born somewhere near Paris or in
Paris and there's a bit of dispute about
exactly when she's born some scholars
think later some scholars think earlier
so we're sort of a lot of these dates
are kind of provisional we know that
help that that Abelard himself is born
in brittany which is kind of
rough-and-tumble area and Ken France and
he boarded a noble family and he's
actually you know he's expected to go on
and become a knight but his father who
somehow along the line got himself an
education of sorts decided that he would
give his kids an education and gave them
an educational sort and Abelard really
took to him and Abelard liked it so much
that you decided he was going to give up
his inheritance and give up the whole
Knightly way of being and become a
scholar so we passed that on to his
brothers let them take care of that but
you know he retained that very
aggressive contentious honor driven kind
of attitude throughout most of his
teaching career and that got into a lot
of trouble as a lot kicked up shortly
so Eloise we don't know much about her
childhood we don't know much about
what's going on what we do know is that
she has an uncle and this uncle
Dada's recognize this guy Fulford who's
going to play an important role in the
story we we see that he recognizes that
she's very bright and he does what he
can to further her education as she
probably was somebody who is very easy
to educate which is a docile right but
not Donald the sense of just you know
going a lot of things die all that she
could be taught and by the time that
Abelard comes to paris and it's starting
to think about GUI he would like as a
maid
she already has a reputation well
established within you know this
Parisian region there's an intellectual
you know Center for being brilliant for
you know learning philosophy learning
all these other liberal arts we don't
know any particulars about this
unfortunately it would be great if we
had you know records from from the time
but we don't but what ends up happening
is a Mellark himself he goes any studies
in Paris with William of Shopville and
Emma lark is one of these students who
must have really been a major pain for
anyone who was teaching it because he
always does show up how smart he is now
the teachers that he's dealing with they
were not for a straight so a first-rate
teacher can take somebody like that and
spin that that rough chaff into gold
right when you're dealing with people
where the student really is starting to
surpass when the master then you get it
you get into real problems and he ends
up you know having a couple different
what's called teaching assignments here
and there there's a couple trips back to
Brittany you know to deal with family
matters and eventually he comes back to
Paris and it's entire time when he's
been studying and when he's been dealing
with is what what they're called
dialectic essentially what we would now
call logic in the market
okay well so Plato has a discipline of
dialect degree that he talks about in
the Republic and that is this back and
forth question and answer proposing the
thing looking for the holes in the
argument so it is very argument based
and that was a discipline that was
flourishing at the time especially in
Paris and he's surpassing his teachers
so this means that other people are
flocking to him and becoming his
students which really coverage teachers
now he did have a patron this guy stuff
into Garland who it plays you know some
big parts in the story it's always
helpful they had somebody bill you know
kind of get you back and and keep you
from incurring the wrath of the powers
that be and so now to sort of jump ahead
to where Eloise comes in a Millar
decides that if you tell you about this
in his history of his calamity the
letter that you write so he told me he
tells us that he didn't he women really
liked him he was kind of debonair sort
of guy right well cultured good-looking
he was writing popular songs at the time
so he's kind of a rock star don't make
it on when we now didn't look at a rock
star and and he was like I don't want
that you know I don't want to get
entangled with them now he's also in a
kind of strange position where he
because he's teaching in religious
schools he's in effect considered where
what's called a minor clergy not not you
know monks him and
and full fledge for others not as
definitely not a priest but he's still
supposed to be changed you know so he's
not suppose to be going around having
sex but a lot of people were kept
observing this in breach the way a lot
of rules are and so he says I I need to
find somebody who's going to be you know
worthy of me by Eagle Eddie settles on
Eloise and he probably could not have
picked a better person at the time
because apparently she is quite
good-looking and brilliant and as it
turns out both of them really have
strong sexual appetites both of them
have a deep capacity for love and
affection and both of them also don't
mind breaking the rules
well what ends up happening is Abelard
he goes to her uncle and he says I would
like to watch in your your house I'd
like to be you know paying room and
board because it's you know very
convenient it's nearby the school and
I've got a household but it's costing me
too much and and full-bird you know he
sees this and he's like this is perfect
because now my niece who's I know is a
great student brilliant she can study
with some claps teacher the guy that
everybody is saying and we gotta go
study with she gets to study with him so
he he drives what he thinks is a hard
bargain he tells them you're going to
spend as much time with my niece as
possible and you're going to teach her
all the stuff that they can and he knew
BC exam yeah oh you mean you mean
Abelard I have a largest exactly
entirely about that so what is it's
happening they do in fact engage in some
intellectual conversation because they
love books and they talk about you know
Cicero or Seneca or
all these different people but they also
spend a lot of the time fooling around
and having sex and writing these love
letters back and forth to each other
even though they're in the same place
you know
and an Lord said that his work really
goes to pot because because he's no
longer you know when he was teaching
he's no longer like developing new stuff
he's kind of falling back on the old
stuff and again if we think about like
rock stars right this might be a good
way to put it in perspective you know
they get involved in some romantic
relationship and they're really happy
but they're not doing their best work
well in this case Hamlet is still
writing songs and it's awnser great but
his songs are starting to get around and
pretty soon people are coming to full
burn and saying do you know what your
niece is doing do you know if your
lodger is doing you know they're doing
together is it nod nothing like that is
happening she's really chaste and I know
that he would never do anything like
that because he in the very
self-controlled man and meanwhile you
know they're doing all sorts of things
you know just raising and raising the
bar for the heights that they're harder
can control to this entire time so
pretty predictably enough she becomes
pregnant and now they have to figure out
what they're going to do so they leave
they go to they go to Brittany and
there's a strategic reason for doing
this by going there and this is really I
think you know if you think about the
logic it's a little disconcerting
Abelard can say well full-bird won't do
anything to me because he knows that if
I got say injured or killed then my
relatives would probably do so
Louise so he's putting his his lover at
risk by doing this I will means it's
fine with it apparently though she yeah
we don't really know that much she may
have wanted to get out of town she's
certainly totally captivated with the
Abelard and they they then get married
and Eloise doesn't want to get married
Abelard says if we do get married it's
going to damage my reputation of it but
it'll get your uncle who really wants to
kill me a lot of off of our back and
they go through this whole thing which
is an i terrible idea it's not going to
get him off your back I just want you I
don't need an institution of marriage
you know she she's very explicit about
she says I'd rather be your concubine or
[ __ ] than me your wife and and but they
do get married and it's at a secret
ceremony and then they go on trying to
negotiate with filbert and again Eloise
is saying look this guy's not going to
be reasonable
don't even try the Abelard does and they
have a sort of reconciliation and then
something happens to those of the
separation that you're asking about
so Abelard goes off to one place and she
goes to this nunnery and ardent way she
isn't the baby yet no she does stuff to
the baby yeah okay yes yeah yeah and his
name is astrolabe we were talking about
this earlier she chooses the name
there's nobody else named astrolabe you
know it's a piece of machinery it's sort
of it would be sort of like if you were
super captivated with you know Apple
computers
just mass because rivers what they put
to it because she has the baby before
Sheila Mary um no they they get married
and then they have a baby and they don't
really keep they don't keep the baby
with them they do keep the baby but you
know it's essentially farmed out to
relatives and raised by relatives now
she then goes to architrave and she did
come and done yeah she she's just there
and at that time that that made stuff
there were lots of people who would hang
around religious institutions and were
you know like maybe considering whether
they would join it or not but they
weren't actually fully there and we'll
talk about that in a bit that's part of
the culture but full Girt it appeared
thought that Abelard was trying to put
her away and so he thought Ambler had
kind of gone that other deal and then
this horrific thing happens where
full-bird sentence men to castrate Peter
Abelard
now they do druggin his own servant is
involved and in the middle of the night
they they tie him up the castrate him he
wakes up and this is you know sort of
the centerpiece of his calamities that
he writes about he ends up becoming a
monk at the monastery of st. Denis which
is very important monastery in the area
and she she ends up because Abelar tells
her to do so taking Manasseh
yourself and becoming another so you've
got a married couple who you know just a
sort of recap you've got a married
couple both of them are brilliant
scholars both of them are these people
with a very deep capacity for love and
affection both of whom also have great
erotic desire separated from each other
horrible thing has happened to him which
means affordable thing is equally
happened to her they can't actually
consummate their marriage now they're
both in religious communities and she's
you know she does it but she does it for
him
she doesn't do it because she she wants
to be you know an honour or seek out God
or something like that and then we you
know as we go forward with the story
what we see happening is at large
himself he moves around a bit from
monastery to monastery he goes at one
point he's in Brittany and he becomes an
abbot to the monks there and they
dislike him so much they try to poison
well no they it seems like the Romana -
Terry's and actually add that to other
not you know the Economist at the time
where they were kind of lacks and
discipline I like to have a good time
this appears some kind of one of them
and Abelard and learn also didn't speak
their language you know those are mostly
Breton's
and he didn't actually speak Breton so
imagine having some guy you don't see
like having a boss come in sent by you
know corporate he doesn't know you at
all and he's going to tell you what to
do and even screwing around the entire
time
until three times right the UI you might
try together and they try to poison
twice they actually had that killed
killing one other guy in the process by
mistake so he that doesn't work out he
also it doesn't really work out that
well
saint-denis in part because she gets
into an argument with some of the other
monks about whether the damn it you know
be it missus or dennis really was the
one who's mentioned in the literature
and so there there's all sorts of
interesting things going at what I would
say one of the really important things
that happens is that he's eventually
given permission to start a hermitage a
hermitage is different than a monastery
the hermitage is a place where you go
off and a monastery is going to kind of
a whole community Hermitage was
something smaller and he called it the
Paraclete after you know the helper
right the Holy Spirit and you know
during this time Eloise is you know in
her monastic or her current nunnery and
there's there's a you know be the abbot
of one of the later Abbot's of st. Denis
has got his eyes on taking it over and
eventually he does he accuses her and
her her Abbess she's a prior at the time
Prioress and the rest of nuns of
immorality which is a way to sort of win
that sort of battle and he also produces
what look like with the scholars think
of forged documents to try to take it
over and he succeeds them doing it which
means these nuns are like well they got
to go wherever they can
so some of them go along with the Abbess
at the time but many of them I lacked
Eloise and new at Abbas and they they go
to along with her and what a Millar does
is he needs over the Paraclete to Eloise
and these nuts so you know his the abbot
you're sort of officially is being a
real jerk to them he'll he'll fix the
situation by taking what he's got would
he build out the middle of nowhere and
giving it to them and then for quite a
while he was out of touch another story
gains to these these letters that we're
going to talk about in a bed
what a velar does is he writes a letter
that's called the history of my
calamities then he writes it to a friend
of his I guess had had really hard time
and Abelard is basically saying you
think you have a rough time wait'll you
hear would happen to me it happened it's
now in the story that he tells Eloise
comes up over and over again and in in
you know medieval times when you write a
letter and your letter was pretty good
people would often copy it and then
circulate it right letter gets
circulated around and Eloise gets one
and then she starts reading it and now
I'm tangent you know so you've got a
husband and he had this whole long
history and he hasn't been in touch with
you for a long time and then you find
out he's writing other people and
talking about you and so you know she
doesn't actually say this in her letters
but you get the sense that there's a bit
of what the hell what are you doing in
putting that there
and so she begins writing to him back
and forth and she really still wants to
have a deep relationship with him and he
still needs fancy write that that's part
of what she's going to be pushing for
she says you you have an obligation to
me and that makes it okay for you by the
way as a monk to be writing me a nun
because we are still we are still
married I really want you know you'd be
so great I love you so much and want
this from you and he might add name is
kind of cold fish and he gives her
pastoral advice about how you know
and he also argues was there have been
in the letters so they go back a couple
times and then it's finally clear to her
that she is not going to get what she
wants from this guy well so that's what
we'll talk about that in the better you
he's she's asking for something that
that that he could have given in terms
of writing yeah and in terms of their
past and he keeps reframing it so
eventually they do carry on a further
correspondence where she is asking him
for some advice about you know dealing
with with the responsibilities that she
has with the night she also gives him a
set of biblical questions
it has him try to you know answer those
for her or not
oh these people are reading the Bible
over and over again oh there's a lot of
passages of the Bible Bible where you're
like I have no idea what the hell's
going on here what's this about so
admire is one of the people who try to
tackle them and then you know their
their life goes on he ends up having a
worse time after that he hadith even
being accused of heresy by Bernard
sort of a rising guy Bernard Clerval
PISA Cistercian there's you know some
reconciliation but he's also sort of
silenced by that time and he dies he
dies in 1142 she lives on wait a long
time after that another 20 years
continuing the work and yeah that's we
don't have any writings unfortunately
from from that that time other than a
few letters to Peter the venerable and
that's really unfortunate because I
think that she if we had things that she
had written say for the use of her nuns
or about you know about her version of
the calamities I think it would be
really quite striking so we do have
these these letters now before we look
at those I want to notice a few things
about a few key aspects of the culture
that they're living in so monasticism
plays a central role and if you spend
any time with mocks or nuns outside of
the confines of like going to say
Catholic school or something that you
you know go to a monastery you realise
just how diverse their their lives and
outlooks really are and it was even more
so in medieval times where this is a
central institution of Western culture
many of them were Benedict ins so
they're following the rule of Saint
Benedict Benedict was was a you know
late ancient figure early medieval
figure and essentially you know what you
see happening towards me early for the
Middle Ages is they take this monastic
way of life that had already been
developed in the deserts of Egypt and
Palestine and and make it central in
and what we don't walk over the dark
ages the beginning of the Dark Ages and
the monks were really the drivers of
culture for a long time they were they
were the ones who were literate they
were preserving manuscripts of copying
them yeah now that's a bit later so
they're there you're talking about other
orders like Dominicans and Franciscans
but so these monks they're not only
preserving culture they also were
incredibly important for reclaiming the
land you know you put in a monastery
they're not only living this religious
life where they're getting up to pray at
certain times they're working because
the benedicted in a way is to pray and
work and so they would you know
inevitably towns would it would arise
around them and there are many people
who are involved with the monasteries
who weren't themselves monks or nuns who
were kind of trying it out you know they
might be going there also for schooling
because many of them had to have schools
it was quite common for married people
towards the end of their life to with
each other's permission to enter
monastic life as nuns or than once as a
matter of fact one of the people who I
worked on st. Anselm who's been earlier
Ansem Anselm of Canterbury he's he's a
he's a previous century and a little bit
into their century he had to write a lot
of letters where he's telling somebody
this guy wants to become a monk I know
he's married to you but look he's old
but under a monastery
what's a killer Kurt and so this is kind
of a common thing at the time and so
monastic life turns out to be very
important and for somebody like Eloise
she had quite a bit of freedom and a
scholar with full Burke but that's an
unusual household that wouldn't been the
case for most women appetite in the
monastery or rather in her
and she has way more freedom you know
especially as she's becoming the person
who essentially getting kicked upstairs
because she's so competent and she came
the prior prior s who's the sort of
second in commandment of a madness the
Abbess runs the whole thing the Abbess
can powers essentially of ambition in
their Abbey so it's very authoritative
post it also has a great amount
responsibility dealing with all of these
these possessions apparently she did
such a great job that they were able to
have six sister houses developing out of
their their house and originally another
really important aspect of the story is
the development of the school's Peter
Abelard is going to Paris to study in
the schools and to teach in the schools
and that that's what allows them to come
together at all
the schools are still affiliated
primarily either with monasteries or
with cathedrals we don't yet have the
University at Paris yeah right a
distinct thing but it's getting close
another important aspect of this is the
sort of the notion of love and
friendship and the institution of
marriage of what it means interestingly
a lot of the monks themselves were
playing an important role in rethinking
this you might say well what the hell
would they know there Sullivan
okay well ancient literature had had
passed on the ancient literature these
monks of reading and passed on ideas
about what a marriage ought to look like
so from Cicero we get this you know on
friendship and on Tricia has this
disturbance is Latin term read amare to
love in return and there's a lot of
discussion among the monks about exactly
what that means
love in return yeah to give love back
for the love that you're getting what
would that what would that involve for a
married couple you know and he mentioned
st. Anselm's st. Anselm's himself so
this is you know 50 years earlier was
giving marital advice to couples and
telling telling them you need to be
loving each other and you know becoming
friends with each other there's this
whole kind of movement I mean there were
a lot of people who were marrying at the
time too you know they wanted to connect
families together they wanted to marry
up and make some money you know that all
the things stuff that's going on again
right but there was also this emphasis
on you know marriage should ultimately
involve love and if not you know then
then what else should be men and women
be doing together you know you see you
see with Eloise a lot of very sustained
reflections on this so those are I think
really important aspect the other key
aspects to that goes to the castration
it's also a society that doesn't have a
stable judicial system in place right so
a lot of the a lot of the justices being
needed up his private vengeance so full
Bert in some respects thought that he
was doing something that was okay he
didn't think it was that okay because
then when he got accused of it he denied
you know having like ordered the hit so
he clearly he was completely on gaining
but it was you know there was a lot of
how things were done and two of the
people who were involved with that were
themselves castrated and huh
yeah for having done that say Abelard
they were caught and it was probably
this guy Steven the Garland's man who
caught them and then you know exactly
the same sort of vengeance upon them
full burden soft person scot-free
nothing happened here well no no
actually I take that back he he actually
did lose his possessions he has
possessions countries so that was there
was a bit of an issue for him now let's
talk about Eloise and I give you some
selections from her letters some of the
key themes I wanted to to bring out here
the one of the first one is that it's
okay for them to be writing letters back
in point to each other that if they if
they want to behave like a married
couple
even though they are in religious orders
it would be entirely appropriate for
them so she tells them you know we can
write each other so innocent a pleasure
is not forbidden this let's not lose the
only happiness which has left us you
know I will read you're my husband you
shall see me address you as a wife so
it's interesting to see this interplay
between two people who have taken
religious vows and she's saying we
essentially we can have it all except
for the sex part and he's of course
being to turn her down but notice the
sort of things that that she's saying
she says letters were first invented for
comforting some solitary wretches as
myself I shall see it I in some measure
this will compensate the loss by the
satisfaction I will find in your writing
I can have you back Abelard in your
letters not not because you're any
ordinary person but because you're the
kind of person who can communicate who
you are and our relationship through
your letters if you choose to so she's
opening up a possibility for him you
know I mentioned that she had a portrait
of him
that she would look at each day and then
actually more than once a day
committed and and she she wants
something like that in terms of letters
letters are more articulate than
portrait because in a letter you can be
your your innermost thoughts so she says
you know I'll read your secret though
I'll carry them about with me I will
kiss them every moment you know if you
can be a capable of jealousy let it be
for the caresses I don't stow on your
letters and envy only the happiness of
those rivals so she says this is what we
can do together she's proposing a way of
continuing their love affair so that's
one important theme
another interesting theme in this other
passage here she says I no longer a
shame that my passion has had no balance
for you I've done more than all this
I've hated myself so that I might love
you I came hither to ruin myself in a
perpetual imprisonment that I might let
make you live quiet and easy nothing but
virtue joined to a lot of perfectly
disengaged in the Commerce of the senses
could have produced such effect vice
never inspires anything like this she's
talking about the depth of her love for
him and the fact that she took on
monastic vows not because she wanted to
but because he asked her to and you know
she says when we love pleasures we love
the living and not the dead we leave off
burning with desire for those who could
no longer burn for us this is my cruel
uncle's notions he measured my virtue by
the frailty of my sex I thought it was
the man not the person who I loved so we
see this emphasis on you know what
full-bird it can't and having a mulatto
castrated was to try to remove the
possibility of any sort of consummation
lost right and she's saying I really
like that but that's not health of the
buckle that's not what this is
fundamentally about my uncle got things
wrong he didn't realize that I love you
not just because you know we have
different you know sex roles and engage
in all this play but because you were
you know like to say soulmates or a
kindred spirit that's what she's saying
to him and he says she says I love you
more than ever and to revenge myself of
him I was still love you with all the
tenderness of my soul until the last
moment of my life so that's another key
theme oh well this is part of why when I
when I was teaching that class on love
friendship a desire I wanted to have my
students encounter something like this
because you know I don't think we we get
sappy romantic messages a lot in movies
or things like that I don't think we get
this sort of stuff and it's good to have
models you know a lot of students I
suppose probably read it they're like
yeah II probably should have you know
top somebody officer but they're you're
not getting it okay some of them are
responding to like oh my gosh what is
this going on here here in the next
passage we see why feminist scholars in
particular have been very interested in
Eloise she's in fact rejecting the oh
she's made an appeal to the institution
of marriage she's rejecting what most
people do with marriage in us she says I
knew that the name of life was honored
over the world and holy and religion yet
the name of your mistress had greater
charms because it was more free I could
give myself freely the bonds of
matrimony still bear with them a
necessary engagement I was unwilling to
love a man who perhaps with
always loved me and she makes a
distinction here she says it was love
really about she says it's not about
money it's not about ceremony it's not
about you know all this other stuff that
people all throw into it and the reason
why they get you know so eager about
this stuff it really has to be about the
person him or herself and loving them
for for who they are
so she says a little bit early a little
bit further down she says I can never
think this is the way to enjoy the
pleasures of an affectionate Union so
she's not you know dismissing sacks or
enjoyment of things that's that's all
part of it but that that's not that's
not the the affection it's just Noor to
feel these secretive charming emotions
of hearts that long strove to be United
these brave partners of marriage pine
for large fortunes which I think they
have lost and here she points out a
problem that comes up in marriages the
wife sees husbands richer than her own
and the husband wives better portion
than his their interest involves
occasion regret and regret produces
hatred so if they get into it for the
wrong reason right this is this is
essentially you know we talked about
trophy marriage right in the president
where you have a guy he's got he's got
plenty of money and he's interested in
this woman because she's really
good-looking and probably has a good
personality at least you know for the
time being and him too you know and they
get together and if you if you get
together on that sort of basis well you
can always find somebody else who's got
more money or you can always find
somebody else who seems more attractive
you know for whatever reason and so they
start doing this comparison they're not
loving each other for who they
fundamentally are it's going to lead to
problems later huh so she says if
there's anything that can be called
happiness I'm persuaded at the union of
two persons who love each other with
perfect liberty perfect freedom who are
united by a secret inclination and
satisfied with each other's merits
they're totally content
and she thinks this can be done apart
for marriage which is a very
revolutionary thing to be saying at the
time in 12 century Europe
okay keep it up yourself yeah I think I
think there's there's crazy people to
think so if you are if you found
somebody you really are serious about
your relationship well you should get
married right and there's probably we
have a very high divorce rate not just
because we made it easy to get divorces
but because you know people do get
divorced because at a certain point they
say I can't stay in here
you know I don't want to be I don't want
to be around you or they want to trade
up I need to change yeah I just want to
keep the children no which makes a big
difference yeah family law gets very
complicated sometimes nowadays it varies
too from state to state like New Jersey
is a funny state you still have like
alimony for life and you know you got to
like catch somebody doing something
lowball states now have no fault no
borders yeah well if we get another a
couple other games here she tells him is
that another passage I didn't become a
nun because I felt called to it I did it
because you asked me to do it and you
know here she says I essentially risked
it all for you
she says Here I am here I will remain
for this place an unfortunate long and
my cruel relations have condemned me but
if you Abelard your actions continue
your concern for me what am i gain what
recompense can I hope for and she said
I'm having a really hard time as a nun
veiled as I am I'm in such disorder how
difficult it is to fight always her duty
against inclination I know an obligation
that Vail days on me but I feel more
strongly with power of law individual
hands over my heart I'm conquered by
this when I love troubles my mind and
disorders my will sometimes I'm swayed
by piety the next moment I yield up my
imagination to all that is amorous and
tender social sanctum look I still love
you I still desire you as a man sexually
I want to have something with you that
will allow me to integrate myself so I
not split in two different directions
you know trying to be a good Abbess for
my nuns and not be a hypocrite and
direct myself towards the God who I
actually do believe in and at the same
time you know hold on to what I know
what we had was you know just amazing
can't you collaborate with me a vallarta
so she'sshe's in effect asking him for
that and she a little bit further I
mentioned this week before we begin
she's talking about how unfair all of
this is and she says you know we were
miserable at a time when we seemed the
least to deserve it when we were
fornicating and screwing around on
behind my uncle's back and abusing his
trust and all that sort of stuff
everything was going great and of course
I did get pregnant but you know things
are still going great no punishment for
me or anything like that and then you
know we take a lot and we decide we're
going to do the right thing we're going
to get married we're going to reconcile
with my uncle and that's when everything
goes terrible what kind of God is just a
sum of none what kind of God you know
does this how is this personal you know
is it just like sort of rub our noses in
it and grind us down that's what a boy
actually does end up saying you know
she's so much prettier
you can't respond to her yeah well I
mean I think he could have better get a
choice yeah yeah a little bit further
she talks about you know in order to
make up for the is that we it's not
sufficient that we bear the punishment
we have to change the way that we see
things but I am unable to do that I
can't stop loving you desiring you
valuing what we did have and yet I know
that I want to have peace I need to do
that so getting to this this yearning
for a reintegration that her lover could
her former lover could provide her and
he chooses if you read his letters and I
didn't want to talk about his luggage
too much but we'll just say this if you
look at his letters his responses to her
are not very they're not at all similar
there he more like hey be careful you
know you're making this complaint and
really you should be looking at it this
way this is he actually says that at one
point it was good for him to be
castrated that it freed him up to pursue
God the way that he shouldn't and that
you know be involved with lost and he's
he was essentially giving her the
impression that she needs to Canada she
needs to put it put it up aside and it's
very his answers very honest at the back
so she can go yeah I think you learn
she never she never gets what she was
asking for she's very clear about what
she's asking for why it would be
legitimate how it would help her she
tells us a lot of great stuff about the
nature of love and a really fundamental
deep relationship on the way but the
tragic part is that
doesn't have a real partnering Abelard
by that time who will really respond to
it so that's sort of a great place to
leave that I did want to tell you a
little bit about some of the later
developments and interpretations that
come up and will maybe spend some time
to do more Q&A and discussion so it
doesn't take all that long before the
stories start circulating and there's a
guy
Jean de Bowman who writes a work that's
very very popular in the Middle Ages
called or rolled onto the rolls yeah and
their story figures in there now this is
you know about a really it's over a
century after she dies so plenty of time
has passed
he also publishes about 15 years later
in 1290 a French translation of their
letters and Cortney Jean de book I'll
give it to you a little bit later I can
give you my notes here now about 350
years after their their time there's
another monk who is named as Johannes
Azaria and he is from Clerval which is
where Bernard had been Bernard with
persecuted Abelard or prosecuted him you
know like they're basically the same
thing at the time for him and he you
know he finds in the Paraclete these
this parchment scroll and he's
interested in the letters that are
contained in the parchment scroll
there's no names of the letters so he is
he'll publish this eventually in the
letters between two lovers he was
interested in them primarily for style
he's looking at how they address each
other at the start of the letters but he
also includes some of the content so
some scholars think that those are the
letters that
Abelard and Eloise wrote each other when
they were actually engaged with each
other living living in full Burt's house
and writing on these wax tablets that
you could I mean here's the thing so
they could write a platen to each other
none of the servants would know what
they're lighting they could be writing
whatever dirty things they want and they
apparently they did and then they say
goes go take this to the sewing cell and
they had a perfect pretext were you know
we're studying together we're working
Cicero Harris toddler or whatever and
she would copy them out to this thing
and so it was preserved and a lot of
scholars think that that that is
actually they're they're they're they're
letters later on they get quite a bit of
discussion bye-bye people throughout
time Patrick was one of the people who
thought that they were very interesting
he he had some copies of their letters
he viewed them as part of a 12th century
Renaissance and was going on he thought
you know most of the Middle Ages was
garbage but you know people like Eloise
and Abelard they were really something
you know so it was all dark ages we see
other people taking up the theme
throughout the time so Pope you know
will write sort of what he imagines
Eloise is saying the Avalon and back and
forth jean-jacques Rousseau writes a
novel you know with nouvelle Eloise
which refers to the story Mark Twain's
book the innocents abroad is a reference
to Eloise and Abelard it's a satirical
version other than other ones where
people actually like created fictional
novels with these two because
well it's easy because because there's
there's there's so many gaps that can be
filled that die so if you're a creative
writer you know with lots of room even
the story of oh you know a piece of
French erotic literature from the 20th
century brings up some stuff from Eloise
of the Abelard primarily quoting the
thing about Eloise saying she would
rather be a Ballards [ __ ] that the
bride of the Roman Emperor himself
Owens Julie who the new belt Eloise
julier the new Eloise and so their story
has continued to fascinate people I mean
they're big wood will be versions and
songs written on yeah and why is that
well it's a grand yeah together it's not
just a one one-sided story there's so
many things that like where it could
have gone right and went wrong and and
that's what's dealing with that uncle is
crazy revenge that he decides to take
out Abelard
but even afterwards they they could have
kind of Abelard have been ready to
respond to Eloise and the way that she
was offering they could have had a great
loving relationship carried out through
the letters he doesn't do it so there's
this missed opportunity there
well I've never I didn't know that
movies have been made in which it plays
apart that I've never I've never
actually seen any of them at mom I don't
know that actually that's kind of an
interesting idea
could you make a really good movie I
think a lot of people wouldn't like to
see it right because it's you know
doesn't have a happy ending good doesn't
triumph over evil
many people like medieval stuff oh you
mean the afternoon from the bloody well
that wouldn't be the first movie that
you know closely person stuff all the
luck around
it's tough to do to it and when you read
me when you read novels especially when
there's a lot of inferiority and you get
to see what the characters are thinking
you can't just do that with like a
voiceover you have to find some way to
leave it in I've never tried my head of
script writing so I can't I imagine it
must be pretty difficult you give them
the other questions or comments of happy
to spend more time chatting about this
and I think for all of their questions
along the way beautiful story yeah I
miss you already cavity since I came so
late I was interested in the difference
in philosophy for example he you know
she she wasn't very much into I think
spend together well they both Lea
grudges okay thanks
she had a different interpretation um
she she's quoting Seneca in part they're
in the letter that we have to save
something himself
we would talk about it with his friends
with chilliest that a letter is almost
like having your friend there you know
and I think you know he it was kind of a
common place at the time people
they both believed that they did study
philosophy together how did he do it how
did they different yeah well I mean we
it's hard to say because we have some of
the Abba lines on philosophy but we
don't have anything that she wrote as a
philosophical treatise you know where we
can compare them we do know that she
brings up some key themes that will show
up later on in his philosophy like the
notion that intention is what matters in
ethics not the actual action or its
effect with the intentional law was
what's what's key she brings that up in
her letters and then he later on so it
could be that that was something they'd
agreed upon before it could be that
something where he's like oh yeah that
makes a lot of sense I'll incorporate
that we don't really know unfortunately
what we would need is more more material
by her yeah so be able to really compare
it we know when it comes to like their
take on a particular situation they
clearly disagree and you thought that
you know God punished us or not so let's
make the best of it it's you saying no
no this is what's making the best of it
you know when we are married so we can
do this you know and he just we gotta go
along with it yeah yeah she is
difficult moment well they're there if I
remember right there is another
contemporary who she never met who is
also I when Emily red Pizza was around
the same time that Hildegard of Bingen
yeah hunting total the guard of bingen
so further further east so there would
other there were other brilliant women
you know it was a very difficult time to
for them to do much so they're probably
a lot of other brilliant women who never
had a chance to do anything other than
get out of the kitchen getting into the
religious life opened up a lot of
opportunities for them because then it
would I mean she was able to she was
able to continue studying she actually
we know this from a letter that somebody
else wrote she actually got into a
argument with Bernard of Clairvaux and
corrected him about about you know
biblical interpretation and she could do
that because she could read Greek Latin
and Hebrew that was extremely I mean
even for men at the time that was
unusual for a woman at the time very
unusual and only only being involved in
all sort of institutions would have
given her much of an opportunity she
their son Oh an astrolabe yeah that
money Peter and her apparently both have
some connection but it's not like he's
you know hanging out for months at a
time with them you had you asked me
about this before
he doesn't that becoming a suspicion
month and we know this because they kept
track of like who enrolled and there
couldn't have been more than one a
sterling yes I don't think there was not
a name and if people are naming their
kids even today as weird as some of the
names people have seen them I don't know
how it was called but they would live
actually stoned in - oh yeah Walton
wasn't overly concerned yeah I'm high
and I think I read that she would fall
in with another woman at a young age and
she did have manuscripts from the
Cathedral that they would give her -
really
okay butt cheek and then yeah I don't
know we don't know about
yeah I mean I've only read bits of her
stuff and quite friendly because of
people like you got to read this you
know yeah yeah yeah it's that not in the
area of my particular expertise but it
could have been their word there were
quite a few people at the time in
monastic life who would be Hermits like
that way where that could happen yeah
and she and then the only time you got
out of the walls with if somebody had
died only the woman she was with died
but then she voluntarily went back in
because they were thinking it and closed
to other very young girls oh I know what
that was it was anything she couldn't
see that by themselves yeah that I don't
know what they do a Royal Family's I
think that if they wanted to get rid of
self-analysis
instead of smothering and whatever like
Shakespeare amended institutions of
sometimes overlap significantly with
whatever oil politics for example in
England after William the Conqueror you
know Duke of Normandy takes over one of
the things that they had to do was to
get rid of all these anglo-saxon Nobles
and one way to do is kill them right so
they they did actually kill some of them
in the battles and stuff like that but
with the gibbet a lot of the others has
said you don't have a vocation for
religious life you're going to become a
monk you know such and such a place and
or not and because then you're not
supposed to be reproducing that's what
so many children and so there were a lot
of people that that happen - there were
there were also invited areas there were
the people who are called the compare
see who are people who decided to become
monks or nuns later on usually in life
like they might have a soldier and then
they're like alright I'm not killing I'm
going to work out my soul and then they
were the ones who are called the
velocity which literally means the
sacristy
the conference and these were the kids
many of them probably had no you know
stay condemned all probably hated it we
were given two monasteries or two
nunneries and they said you're going to
be a month here you go
and probably a lot of them were pretty
unsuited to the life and it's
interesting and some some guy who I do a
lot of more time writes about the
conflicts between the Amati and the
conversing in monasteries could be they
both like say that they're they're
better than the others the conveyers who
say look I understand how world works I
actually chose to be here tonight oh no
blonde er like look I didn't I didn't
screw around in the world like you need
get all dirty with it I've been here the
whole time
you know only if they get it to argue
the financial says it's better if they
don't argue at all neither one is right
that's right yeah you could've had st.
ignatius loyola yeah
conversion yeah I mean he's I mean
that's a much later order but it's a
great example of somebody there are
there so many people who had late
callings you know sometimes monasteries
would actually be founded by somebody to
invent like you know they'd been in the
crusade and they they come back and
they're like I want to be a monk I
happen to have the resources oh here's
my new monastery yeah that's only
Anton's monastery was the guy heroin had
been a you know a soldier and he said
okay starting a monastery was another
alerted guy but but he was a good guy I
started a good monastery so I think what
was really interesting is when you look
at the history of these institutions
great variety between the you know and
the Benedictus you know there'd be they
would be improving and then they would
be declining
improving and declining and so you have
these ways like you know totally corrupt
walks over here and these guys over here
like doing everything right you know and
then give it another two years situation
would be reversed if oh yeah yeah one of
those characters one of the action -
yeah you're look at some of those
characters that they depicted and you
know Tony with the like you think about
somebody like Don they're saying about
that before it there's plenty of
religious people down in hell you know
and that day's it uh infernal because
you know just taking on the habit
doesn't doesn't make you a good person
well thank you ank you very nice dear
that so the next one